- I don't know how to describe
being awkward, but I just ...
Didn't answer that well.
(laughs awkwardly)
(squeaking)
- (laughs nervously)
I'm Emily.
Hi, I'm Emily.
I'm a socially awkward person.
So today, I'm gathering a lot of other
uncomfortable people and
we're gonna make them
stare at each other for four minutes,
uninterrupted eye contact.
- I've been told that I am
socially awkward by friends.
My mom is really sweet though, she's like,
"You're not that bad."
- I get very fidgety and
shaky around new people.
- When somebody's looking
at you, you feel very seen,
and I like to be very unseen.
(laughs nervously)
- I am not excited to
stare into eyes today.
I would rather not do
that, but, we're here.
- It's definitely really vulnerable,
and I also don't know this person at all.
- I think four minutes of
uninterrupted eye contact
will change me as a person.
I'm not sure how, but I'm
excited to give it a go.
- Oh my God.
I don't want to do this.
- [Emily] We're gonna do it.
We're almost there.
- (whispering) Help me Lord Jesus.
- Alright.
Ready.
- I feel nothing.
- Set.
- [Female Voice] Two, one, start.
(awkward music)
- We can blink, right?
- Yeah!
- That would be an impossible task.
- Oh my gosh.
(awkward music continues)
Oh God, I looked away for a second,
but it's fine.
- It's okay.
- Eee.
- Look at me.
- Oh my God I don't wanna look at you!
(laughing and squealing)
- Open your eyes.
- (whispering) Oh my God,
oh my God.
- Alright just breathe.
(deep breathing)
(nervous giggling)
- So what did you do this weekend?
- Um.
- I'm definitely blinking a lot.
- I feel like you're not
blinking a lot at all.
- Really?
- Yes.
- You really aren't.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, blinking a lot
I think.
- Mm-mm.
Looks like, seems totally normal.
- Stop it.
(giggling)
- I'm not doing anything!
(laughing)
- I mean we could do this again.
- No, please!
(laughing)
Please!
(awkward music continues)
(timer chiming)
(gasping)
- [In Unison] We did it!
Yay! (clapping)
- Friendship!
- We did it!
- Yay!
(clapping)
- Ugh!
- Oh my God.
- I suddenly became aware
of every part of my body.
- Same!
- When we could not talk.
- I'm just like, oh no.
- That was actually really good.
- Yeah, that was fun.
- There was like a moment in time
where I felt, like, a warmness
even though like, we're not friends.
- I feel like I had eye sex with you.
(laughter)
- I think I'm gonna need
some time to recover,
but hopefully this will
be like, a new baseline,
to be like, the four minutes was weird,
this conversation is not.
- I mean, now that I've done this,
I feel like I'll probably hold eye contact
a little longer than like,
a second with somebody.
- So like, I kind of feel like I tore down
a wall a little bit, which is like, weird.
- I think we've shared an
intimate experience today,
you know, we can't, we can't go back.
We're bonded forever.
Mm!
(laughing)
- Alright, cut!
(upbeat music)
(squeaking)